yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
if you've already watched my videos
about the scenes and characters of
ax-cut from Zootopia you'll know there
was loads of stuff that didn't make it
into the final movie but before
zootopia's filmmakers decided to tell
the story we know and love of rookie
bunny cop Doody and scam artist Fox Nick
they had a whole host of ideas which
would have taken the movie in completely
different directions yes during the many
years of Zootopia took to develop there
were many interesting stories of
filmmakers considered which never ended
up getting made and that's exactly what
I'm going to look at in this video the
untold stories we never got to see in
Zootopia just before I delve into those
I've got a cool pair of Disney books to
give away from my friends at DK one
lucky winner will receive both
zootropolis the essential guide and also
frozen the enchanted guide each of which
has some lovely images and fun facts in
them for a chance to win all you have to
do is subscribe and leave a comment
about Zootopia on this video the road to
making the Zootopia movie that we know
today
started with a number of ideas which
directed by Ron Howard proposed the
Disney's chief creative officer John
Lasseter for example there was a pitch
to adapt alexandre dumas classic novel
the three musketeers with mice in the
starring roles what the ideas Byron
Howard pitched had in common was that
they all involved walking talking
animals who wore clothes
in fact both Byron Howard and John
Lasseter shared a love of these types of
animations with the Disney classic Robin
Hood being a particular inspiration for
Howard the island of dr. meow was
another story that was considered by the
film makers this story featured a
six-foot tall mad scientist cat that
possessed a savage serum which could
transform children into animals the
concept was pitched as a Roger Corman
1960s style b-movie with the title and
story drawing inspiration from the
science fiction novel the island of dr.
Moreau by HG Wells in which dr. Moreau
who lives on an island creates
human-like creatures by experimenting on
animals
who is also a guardians of the galaxy
style movie pitched called poke the
Bounty Hunter the story was set in outer
space and was about a team of animals
hunting for other animals in space after
considering those stories Howard said
that Lasseter loved the ideas and wanted
to combine the quirky quality of the
1960s style world with the animal
characters from the space pub concept
which led Howard to develop his next
concept a spy movie called savage seas
savage seas was planned as a spoof of
James Bond and starred a jackrabbit spy
called Jack Savage who worked at a place
like mi six where he had a tiny mouse
boss a bit like Judi Dench the movies
first act was set in an animal City
which Jack savage left for the South
Seas in the second act Byron Howard even
had titles ready for a whole series of
related movies such as savage earth the
Savage Land and the savage times however
what he found was that people weren't so
keen on the spy element but wanted to
see more of the animal city from the
first act it was at this point that
Howard decided to set the whole movie in
the animal City keeping the bunny
character and adding a Fox as he felt it
would make a great buddy dynamic as
foxes and natural predators of rabbits
once the filmmakers decided to focus the
film on the animal city of Zootopia the
idea was then developed with a much
darker story than the movie we know
today and it centered around the
character of Nick Wilde as the lead in
this early story there was a much more
overt level of prejudice from the prey
population against the minority predator
population who are forced to were tame
colors the film had a dystopian feel
about it with the tame collars acting to
control predators by shocking them
whenever they became excited or violent
one particular sub story of this
involves Nick setting up a secret
amusement park called wild times just
for predators where they were able to
remove their tame collars and indulge
some of their natural instincts without
being electro-shocked and if you'd like
to know more about the designs of wild
times I talked about that in my video
about zootopia's deleted scenes which
you can click here to watch in this
version of the movie judy was also a
less sympathetic character who initially
supported the colouring of predators she
was a tough police opera
so who chased after Nick when he escaped
from the Zed PD after being put in
prison by the way in the final film that
chase was replaced with Judi chasing
weasel turn through little rodentia
eventually Judi came to realize the
harsh truth about the taming collar when
she secretly witnessed a taming party
for Kozlov son Morris a ceremony in
which the five-year-old polar bear cub
receives a taming collar for the first
time as he gets excited he also gets
shocked by the collar for the very first
time and it was after screenings with
the Disney story trust and later at
Pixar the filmmakers realized that
although the story was interesting the
trophy was just too darker place for the
audience to like this realization came
late in 2014 with the film due out in
early 2016 which meant the filmmakers
had little over a year to change course
so they threw out the tame collar
concept and may Judi the lead character
the story of prejudice was still told
but in a much less overt way and through
the eyes of Judi experiencing
stereotypes as she worked the case of
the missing otter later discovering her
own bias as well so guys what do you
think of those unused stories and do you
think we could see any of the ideas or
characters adapted and reused in a
Zootopia sequel I'd love to hear all
you've got to say in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe and
comment for your chance to win this cool
pair of Zootopia and frozen books if you
enjoyed this video take a look at my
other videos explaining all the deleted
scenes and rejected concepts from
Zootopia and 25 things you didn't know
about the making of the movie and also
coming shortly I'll have a new Zootopia
video on all these two eggs and Hidden
Mickeys you missed in the movie there's
links to all of them right here my full
Zootopia video playlist thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you